ach stadtstaat leute wie man es schon
weg wusste eigentlich
[Musik]
das hat unter http www
sieh dich den leute denn heute gibt es
wieder eine neue folge des politischen
zurzeit nur de rossi gesperrt
wir haben john charles saatchi tv würges
face kleinen riese gegen cdu und csu
die kammer kam gegen schwächer so
stimmen hat sie das auch
[Musik]
weiter habt ihr schon eine idee dürfte
jeder ein außer form ja dass ich so ein
ding aus ist dann macht dem motto über
die wir haben wir viel aus wie ich
dachte die hauptzutaten muss jetzt sagen
okay ach und da sind schon geil das über
sagt isa in die andere nicht anstecken
deswegen tragen masken mainstreamig
aufzug oder mit luz zusammen machen
vanessa
[Musik]
du bist das war mein erster gedanke als
zugesagt dass es keine zweifel
wir gehen jetzt einkaufen
hierzu führt ihn in der community jetzt
die ich machen bahnhof und ich hab nur
noch ihr tod gefunden haben
auf die habe ich gekauft hat meine
mutter geklaut
[Musik]
wir müssen noch drei sein dürfen
ok sie gingen einkaufen und verschwinden
dabei in 321 der maria war ging es doch
ganz kommentiert dass wir heute in
meiner küche sind
ich habe auch nicht kommentieren meine
haare halb so großen wir sind zurück vom
einkauf er hat zwar super anstrengend
[Musik]
wer möchte seine zutaten zuerst
vorstellen warum steht da wie ich sie
verstehe ich mag es mich meine zu 1000
vor richtige moment für alle gerade mal
1 jahr
[Musik]
ich würde das auch genau ist keines mehr
mit
die bahn ist es sowas ist das also war
überhaupt vieles beide ausgesucht ist
das was man kennt
[Musik]
oder wie man auch auf den schreck
zitrone kaktusfeige oder wie man auch
chinesische aktienfonds haben ja wort
gab
ich habe schwarzen tee mit zitrone
ingwer energy drink ich habe eine ananas
also ich das nächste mal habe ich meine
eltern besuchen kann man sehen wie viel
alkohol sie bestimmt richtig stellen wie
bambus stolz auf mich war das richtig
seit der mitte des saales im fürs auge
des zuschauers schon angst vor der brust
hat und das auch noch was machst du denn
heute sagen kritiker du hast doch
besserung focus online das ganze weil
ich nach dem kopf des mädchens mein
absoluter ernst leute es ist 15 uhr und
ich habe heute noch nichts getrunken
multifunktion hab so viele auf einmal
passagier aus war wirklich die zu krass
der ecke verkaufen war so von allen
steht um zu ich muss niesen zu holen
weil ich dachte ich habe ja nur
langweilige gläser
berlin
wie man jetzt sagen kurz davor sind die
kohle kommen alles gleich ein glas ins
kanalnetz
[Musik]
alle reden mitarbeiter ja sie kosten
drei euro
ja da wird doch auch wenn ich immer jene
eigenen land kam das versteht nicht was
interessiert in der regel kassier war
das richtig gut wie kassierer fand ich
richtig er war schon leicht nervös also
in der kasse also probieren
da sagte ich habe eine tödliche
infektion ich habe nur der zu leiden
hatte schon gar verwendet hat es alles
viel spaß ich klasse der wagen trotzdem
auch wenn du auf mich standes was sich
das babbel team und west ältere frau am
so 28 jahren vorbeigegangen wieder an am
tisch
vor dem beladen und sie so zu dem der
tisch dafür wann ich stehe ja das ist
der kick das natürlich stehen und
deshalb weiter gegangen ich denke mir
sowas deutsche
[Musik]
ich habe hier ostfriesentee ich brauchte
kommt wasser für mein base charts partie
offensiv valentin fand ich dann weg dann
fand ich ihn eloquent dann war ihr ding
sondern denke ich mir mal so eigentlich
ist das gerade abgegangen ist nur
aufgrund von mangelnder kommunikation
das habe ich aber auch sehr unerwartet
von kathi muss ich sagen aber ziemlich
unter es gibt in jeder youtubes
freundschaft gibt es irgendwann mal die
entscheidung wird uns vielleicht auch
noch trocken
sehen wir die klicks wichtiger oder es
möglich voran schafft pflichten kann man
immer eine sache sagen die ich schon wir
die armut ihre feste zu etablieren kann
expert grüße gehen raus tolle sieht
alles wieder funktioniert fasst vergeht
klicks bleiben ok ich gesagt dadurch
dieser tiere über weil er auch deren
grüner heiratet zwischen geld machen
frage ist eher wahrscheinlich gut finde
ich gut
vanessas klage das könnte wieder eine
chance sein morgan kelly
juli verlängert
[Musik]
man ist kotzt mich voll anders diese
kleinen bälle plötzlich so kleine
fußbälle kommt man nie klar geworden
sind wir auf sagt minuten prädikat
irgendwas hallo ich brauche ein privates
kunstprojekt sollte schätzen und wird
kamera auf dich schneide ich gar nicht
am ende heißen cocktail kann ich meiner
frau doktor ist jetzt wollte ich nur
sagen falls hier
bettina
[Musik]
er kann nicht einfach dieses mal aus
doch langweilig ja das ist auch warum
vanessa dass so was passiert und bewegt
den stopp hier irgendwas platte ist
sehen wir darin hallo geister am
langsamsten vogel wieder drin
das sorgt hier schießt aber aus
[Musik]
ich mache mal mein klub kunden also
davor war gute cocktails und dann
wachsen konnte
ich dekoriere sich ein stern zwei stern
18 sterns das wundervoll und wir sind
fertig ist zu hören dass jetzt alles was
wäre mäßig ist weggeräumt und ich habe
mir muss keiner geholt hatte wenig macht
es bei der wirklich sehr schwerer zu
trinken das ist der dance-charts welches
partie der ti hat sich ja um minus
gedreht bei demenz führt für tobit
elements ist doch ganz viel drin ja war
es noch mehr weiter für sich und viele
hatten 40 vitamin e für sich klar danach
bei der in amerika war und so ein eis
tiefe dieses klassische amerikanische
ich wollte eigentlich ein klassischer
amerikanischer trinkt ja klar
wow schreibt die kommentare leute in
amerika wird ja das wird nur den mut
haben sich ja nicht nur zwei tagen mit
palästen schon die ganze zeit gestritten
über sachen und wir haben nur
gegeneinander google da kommt noch mehr
einfach noch mehr alkohol aus aller welt
also rum tequila auf dem planeten
verteilt weil hertie und die welt ging
so warte hier bitteschön kenne das seit
eigenen probieren weil ich nach winkel
suchen warten muss gleich mal umrühren
noch keiner erklärt mir was du gemacht
seit die europäische darstellt
wenn wir da nicht aufgekommen sterne ich
das dann ich nach hollywood star oder
die priester im sinne zu sein ich hab
den rieser cdu csu
wenn man sie aus gedroht wird und
widerstand ist und das kann ja nicht mit
gelb mission aber dann ist mir
aufgefallen dieser ist eine grüne ist
ziemlich durchsichtig
[Musik]
was willst du bist du kaputt in deinem
kopf ja gut dann muss ich halt noch
glauben machen damit ist ein bisschen
strom sind habe ich mal wieder mal den
arsch gerettet nur probieren konnte ich
den jetzt nicht dann kommt damit um will
dass manipulationen ich muss noch mal
[Musik]
was ist wenn merkwürdiges markt man
werde ja keine klosters von diesen
brienz gemacht das hier ist unsere pace
logo face planlos die stehen ja über
dieses camp und facebooks hatte er so
ein bisschen losgetreten und in dem
vertrag ging es die ganze zeit erstmal
erst mal kurz mit dem fest das ist logo
sehr gut oder habe ich gut das war das
da dafür dass man so ein diamant aus
einer melone schnitzen wollte und das
wurden dann kleine dreiecke verpackt
haben ist das schon ganz gut gewesen
also das kann man schmecken dazu ein
bisschen besser einfach nur zur deko
dann in den drink selber ist schwarzer
tee drin wo ich auch gedacht habe weil
ich anscheinend auf 14 bin mit schwarzer
tee ist auf jeden fall schwarz und wohl
dass eine plastikflasche war dadurch
klar reden konnte und das ist nicht
schwarz
und dann habe ich halt das mit ein
bisschen energy genommen weil es ja
gaming die jagdszene und da reagiert so
ändert wird geändert die schlechte
getränkt aber dann vermischt mit dem
schwarzen tee und unten dann wollte ich
eigentlich noch absetzen so zwanzig
prozent von dem drink den den likör wein
geld besser so für diesen gelben
sunnyboy den tief gespielt weil er hatte
den vertrag 80 20 messe und gateways die
haben
das getränk dass das getränk zu 80 20 20
gegen typ klassischer vertragen ich
probier mal nich 20 gleichgeschaltet
klassischer das große problem dass wir
haben es alle ist für diese eisbären an
weil ich mir dass alles so wässrig
gemacht habe ich fand unsere alle dieses
mal sehr krass west ich habe früher die
reißleine diese also geschlecht sind die
heilung nicht sicher zu sagen ich werde
darum immer das hörte wie so ein
restaurant technik ist es gut dass man
50 zeigt sich auch heute muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ich finde es echt schwer
achten wirklichkeit es wirklich geht
gerade bei der zufolge es ist echt wir
sind mal ehrlich ist im adp heute echt
scheiße beim arag in die entweder wir
entscheiden das keiner gewonnen hat oder
wir suchen ein gewinner aber wenn ich
ein gewinner suchen wollen würde dann
müsste es kenny sein weil der schon sehr
sehr lecker war kennedy krank ist gebe
ich hier auch gerne auf den punkt
[Musik]
die gefahr intelliad geworden was findet
ihr werk irgendwann ja ja aber ich habe
es schon auch ein gutes konzept muss ich
sagen also dass ihre verloren haben war
echt klasse bis 73 kilo und wie du dich
sprechen wir müssen nur singen ja diese
folge leute drauf haben wir durchaus
zufolge denn dann wird es nie
[Musik]
musikalisch denn bei drei cocktails die
wahl anfang an nicht nur unsere köpfe
die mit werden gedacht und die haare
werden und wir freuen uns
meine männer